how much of speed chess is recognizing
positions versus improvising tactics
mostly improvising tactics uh almost
every game goes off the rails at some
point rare is the occasion when you
follow some sort of main line I mean you
can make positional moves in bullet but
it mostly reduces down to oh I see a
cool Square I see the E5 Square my
Knight's on A1 I'm just gonna telescope
onto that square that that's the extent
of strategic reasoning uh that you have
in bullet mostly it's spotting two or
three move tactics so so important to
avoid one move blunders because that
really kills your momentum and I do
think it's important to go into
positions that you generally understand
that's why I was doing King's Indian and
I was playing the Belgrade Gambit which
which is an opening I've analyzed and
played a ton uh on my stream and it it
really brought me a lot of comfort uh
that we had structures where I knew that
I was playing decent ideas but mostly it
is just flash pattern recognition and
almost all games no matter how they
begin ultimately boil down to who sees
more short tactics
is there any sort of advice you can give
to prepare for such an intense match
like this
um I mean I don't think there's anything
specific in terms of advice I think the
main thing is just trying to stay calm
because certainly in Chester there's a
lot of tilt it definitely applies more
to Blitz and certainly to bolts than say
Rapid or classical but the main thing is
always just trying to stay calm because
it's very easy to tilt and lose the game
in like 20 seconds like Andrew for
example in his match against Daniel
there were a couple times where it
seemed like he was getting close and
then like he lost the game and then he
instantly lost that next game in like 20
seconds uh purely due to tilt so
certainly the main thing is just to try
and stay calm and not not I'm not not
lose your minds it's very very easy and
bullet because you only have one minute
for the whole game just like Blitz out
20 moves gotta losing position and then
just just like that you can ruin the
match so overall I mean I I think that's
the most important thing it's just yeah
just relaxing so short repertoire
changed much between uh bullet Blitz and
Rapid chess
um I mean I I would say that the the it
depends on the player I think that some
of the openings that I'm able to use say
against Jose or against uh Amino hanyan
for example uh probably not working as a
player like Andrew Tang uh very
specifically but but generally I think
it's player by player and there are a
couple players where I think some of the
some of the sidelines don't work as well
simply because they're very very fast
um but overall there isn't there there
really isn't that big of a difference
except for a couple of specific players
where I think certainly when I play some
of the nonsense Sidelines they're very
good I think all the rest actually
another player will want to play the
sidelines he's very well prepared for
them so some players are trying to avoid
it but for the most part there isn't a
huge difference between Blitz and bull
between classical and Rapid it's it's
massive and I think that certainly
um there are a lot of openings that In
classical chess I would just never never
use and never use a bullet for sure